- SO LAST NIGHT
WHEN MY GIRL SAID
SHE WANTED TO SLIP INTO
SOMETHING MORE COMFORTABLE,
I DIDN'T KNOW
SHE MEANT A COMA.
[laughing]
HEY, WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
THAT'S FUNNY.
I MEAN, IT'S SAD, TOO,
'CAUSE SHE DIED.
- I'M SICK
OF BEING CALLED UGLY, DENZEL.
THERE'S ONLY SO MUCH
A GIRL CAN TAKE.
ONE DAY I'M GONNA SNAP,
AND WHEN I DO...
- CALM DOWN.
AT LEAST I APPRECIATE YOU.
- REALLY?
- SURE.
UGLY PEOPLE LIKE YOU EXIST
TO MAKE PEOPLE APPRECIATE
HANDSOME PEOPLE LIKE ME.
- I'VE HAD ENOUGH OF THIS!
both: AAH!
AAH!
[water splashes]
- [inhales deeply]
HAHH.
- AAH!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- I WAS SAVING YOUR LIFE.
- NEXT TIME LET ME DIE!
WHERE THE HELL ARE WE?
- LOOKS LIKE
A DESERTED ISLAND.
- DAMN,
IT'S JUST LIKE MY DREAM,
ONLY YOU AIN'T CLORIS LEACHMAN
WITH A HOT WING FOR A CLITORIS.
- I'M SCARED, DENZEL.
WHAT IF NO ONE
EVER FINDS US HERE?
I'LL DIE A VIRGIN!
UNLESS...
- YEAH, I'M GONNA BE REAL SAD
AT YOUR VIRGIN FUNERAL.
[engine revving]